la rentrée la saillie pour prendre soin
le chemin de l'école soit retourné au
boulot soit allé à la fac soit allé à
l'école primaire comment vous enfin à ce
que vous voulez avec une rentrée il faut
s'équiper et il est temps de revoir son
organisation et justement aujourd'hui je
vais vous aider en vous parlant de
l'objet de textes indispensables pour
cette rentrée alors pour cette rentrée
et on a besoin de beaucoup d'objets tels
qu on pourrait le dire maintien j'ai
besoin d'un nouvel ordi j'ai besoin d'un
nouveau smartphone j'ai besoin de sciez
ça oui peut-être mais il ya un objet que
vous ne soupçonnez peut-être pas que
vous n'avez a priori peut-être pas chez
vous et qui pourrait venir vous
solutionner pas mal de problèmes cet
objet c'est celui-là c'est le google
n'est ce mini et cet objet là il est
vachement intéressant bien qu'il soit
petit bien qu'ils soient accompagnés dès
qu'elles soient design léger compagnie
et sans lui en parler si quelques
secondes eh bien il va venir faire plein
de tâches pour vous plein de tâches
intelligente et va venir réellement vous
assistez au quotidien j'ai la chance
d'en rater sollicité par google pour
être ambassadeur nest miliboo en cette
fin d'année donc on va regarder ça en or
par un on reparlera d'autres thématiques
liées à google nest et vous allez voir y
en a beaucoup et c'est extrêmement
intéressant mais aujourd'hui on ressente
vraiment sur cette problématique de la
reprise avec des usa qui sont vraiment
extrêmement fort alors la première chose
très rapidement eh bien regardez j'ai
voulu ouvrir c'est pas un produit qui
est nouveau qui vient de sortir
le google est minime et je suis sûr vous
êtes très nombreux et très nombreuses à
ne pas encore l'avoir chez moi j'en ai
plusieurs jamais google au mini qui
était le prédécesseur de google n'est ce
mini g google est obligé google est au
max autant vous dire que c'est une
solution que j'utilise depuis très
longtemps
sané c'est ça très joli très design
c'est un petit galet qui paye pas de
mine et qui fait vachement de choses
très faciles à installer ça c'est un
point que j'aime beaucoup sur ce produit
là c'est que vraiment vous embêtez pas
je viens de brancher la ici j'ai un
petit bouton il est juste là pour
activer/désactiver micro et c'est
absolument tout je le branche pour le
paramétrer c'est hyper simple il vous
faut un compte google
prérequis il vous faut bien évidemment
une connexion internet très rock qui il
vous faut le google laisse mini est
requis c'est strictement obligatoire
vous téléchargez l'application google
com qui est disponible sur ios mais
également sur android
vous venez créer votre maison vous
l'ajoutez votre maison très facilement
et vous alors que le paramétrage est
vraiment très très rapide pour commencer
téléchargez l'application google au
niveau des hommes la bête est configuré
alors en fait vous avez juste un bouton
play il pose au milieu très facile vous
venez baisser le volume monte le volume
d'à côté jeu
viens baisser le son vous réglez comme
vous voulez et vous avez juste comme je
voulais dire votre petit bouton pour
venir activer le des crocs et désactiver
voilà activer ou désactiver de nouveau
opérationnel donc voyez on a un petit
objet qui est sympa qui est pratique et
design t'es mignon vous le branchez vous
faire plein de choses avec donc ça c'est
l'idée de base
maintenant qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire avec alors pour prendre un peu le
truc vous êtes au travail vous par
exemple vous vous levez le matin
première chose que vous allez faire
c'est lui dire bonjour
ok google bonjour bienvenue découvrons
ensemble la nouvelle route il bonjour
tout d'abord on va vous donner quelques
informations pour commencer votre
journée il vous donne votre âge et il
vous donne la météo il vous donne les
infos je peux aussi allumer les lumières
voyez marais la cafetière
mais exactement nique et plus encore
j'aimais pas besoin de faire la vidéo
lady tout seul ça vous dégrossi déjà pas
mal de choses et ça me permet
d'améliorer significativement votre
productivité ce qui est cool avec cette
petite bête c'est que vous avez accès à
votre agenda ou à demander quels sont
vos prochains rendez vous demandez
combien de temps il vous faut pour aller
à votre prochain rendez vous vous pouvez
connaître tous vos événements pouvaient
en rajouter ok google rajoute mois
rendez-vous google demain 14 heures
d'accord rendez vous avec google demain
à 14 heures la même chose avec un rappel
ok google rappelle moi d'embrasser ma
femme demain matin compris demain à 8
heures pour google rappelle moi que les
clés sont cachés sous le paillasson
ok les clés sont cachés sous le
paillasson quand vous voulez vous
recevoir leurs appels ou demain à 14h
compris je vous le rappelle ray demain à
14 heures
si vous êtes chez vous voulu par là lui
si on pouvait parler directement à votre
smartphone pour vous le rappeler ça
s'écoute et assistants google et c'est
vachement pratique et en plus vous
pouvez lui parler très facilement les
temps en distance parce que grâce à son
micro il va reconnaître votre voix même
si vous parlez de tout doucement
et même s'il ya du brut vous pouvez en
plus se créer une liste de courses
ok google ajoute à ma liste de courses
des bananes des courgettes des tomates
et un potiron
ok j'ai ajouté banale des courgettes des
tomates et potiron à votre liste de
courses vous pouvez connaître la météo à
venir par exemple boudiba tient demain
jean rendez vous otegi google quelle
sera la météo demain à paris le ciel
sera partiellement couvert demain à
paris la température maximale prévue
sera de 21 degrés et la minimale de 11
degrés il y actuellement une alerte
jaune aux orages en cours super beau
temps on voit ça donc ça permet
d'anticiper la tenue pour demain ce nom
mais d'anticiper pas mal de choses et si
vous voulez vous tenir informés des
dates
hier info dernières actualités podcast
vous pouvez lui demander ok google
quelles sont les dernières actualités
économiques voici les dernières
actualités économiques
selon france info le flashy croquer
google arrête la radio comme ça vous
vous donnez informé avant vous préparant
par exemple le matin vous sortez de la
douche vous mettez la radio vous écouter
vous savez tous ces pratiques et c'est
sympa mais vous pouvez aller plus loin
vous pouvez demander par exemple de la
traduction au quai google que signifie
ich liebe dich et shin bet et veut dire
je t'aime en allemand c'est trop mignon
et lorsque vous avez fini votre journée
que vous êtes éreinté et vous voulez
vous faire je sais pas ma pire un petit
gratin aux google lance le minuteur sur
dix minutes compris un minuteur de dix
minutes c'est parti comme ça il fait
tout pour vous et c'est extrêmement
pratique vous pouvez par exemple
demander les horaires de votre magasin
préféré il à faire tout ce boulot pour
vous de façon simple rapide et efficace
ok google qu'elle est meilleur
itinéraire pour aller de paris à nantes
très bien le meilleur moyen pour aller
de paris à nantes en voiture et
d'emprunter à 11
ça prendra environ 3 heures et 50
minutes avec une circulation fluide pour
le moment et lorsque le soir est arrivé
que vous êtes fatigué bien vous pouvez
demander de vous raconter des histoires
à raconter des histoires à vos enfants
si vous en avez met de la musique
écouter tout ce que vous voulez c'est
extrêmement pratique moi cet objet de
laine bien et surtout les services
rendus sont vraiment vraiment vraiment
pertinent à vous de le paramétrer de
personnaliser personnaliser les routines
du matin il pourra piloter votre maison
mais ça on en reparlera un peu plus tard
dont vous invite à venir vous abonner
siph a déjà fait comme ça vous saurez
tout et il ya un autre point qui est
vraiment bien et on se rend pas compte
comme ça on voit ce petit galet c'est
quand même une ancêtre qui est vraiment
de bonne qualité on est sur une source
mono mais on a un son clair on a quand
même des graves pour voir qu'on a
vraiment un petit haut parleur
ça marche bien la qualité est là et en
plus de ça c'est un produit qui pas
particulièrement cher je vous ai mis un
code promo en bas dans la description
aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil
il vous donne droit à 5 euros de
réduction cumulable avec l'offre en
cours à 39 euros 90 pendant tout le mois
de septembre 2020 donc voyez c'est un
objet qui est petit qui élégant qui est
pratique il va devenir vraiment vous
aider dans votre quotidien vous pouvez
tout planifié avec vous vous connaissez
vous rendez vous avez accès à l'actuel
info est ce un objet qui va prendre de
plus en plus de place dans votre maison
non pas par la taille mais par les
services qui va vous rendre à vous de me
dire vous maintenant si vous l'utilisez
si vous utilisez les services google
notamment google assistants et au
travers l'objet le google mais ce mini
personnellement j'aime beaucoup et je
trouve vraiment intéressant et
polyvalent a vous de me dire maintenant
vous ce que vous en pensez en barrant
commentaires si vous l'utilisez quels
sont les usages que vous en avez et
quels sont vos routines ou et marquer
tout ça bien évidemment commentaires
venant se trouve extrêmement rapidement
pour continuer à parler de teck d'objets
connectés
on reparlera très très prochainement de
google n'est ce pas ce qu'il ya plein de
choses à dire sur la maison connectée et
croyez-moi il rend beaucoup de services
sur ce prenez soin de vous et à très
vite on n'a pas beaucoup d'amour tôt
[Musique]